if I look at the year as a whole of
course has been a tough year but your
price being where it was $44 on average
but we have been taking advantage of
that as well
if I look back on the year we're running
a company at a cost level which is ten
billion dollars lower than what it was
twenty four months ago we now run the
combined company at a cost love that was
below the shell stand-alone cost level
we've taken our twenty billion dollars
of capital costs compared to two years
before picking up the divestments and we
still have a lot of growth to come in
the lead up to 2018 we don't plan on
certain or price outcomes for our
financial resilience so we take a pretty
conservative view we are ready to run
the company to balance the company at
all price levels that are significantly
below what it is that we are seeing
today but do you think global oil demand
and supply light because it come into
balance is here I think they are in
balance right now and again how these
balances play out on a month-to-month
basis will continue to be I'm afraid
it's a little bit confusing for markets
to watch this is a very complicated
market but lots of moving parts now as
you say you've been selling assets to
bring down debts including earlier this
week a parcel of North Sea assets which
represented about half your your
business there how committed is shell to
the North Sea now well and it we have
brought on that position quite a bit put
a bit of context around at Ian's and it
is about a bit of a half hour our
production but you know this was
predominantly a very mature set of
assets and we have said very clearly
when we did the BG deal and how we were
going to rejuvenate and reposition the
portfolio we were going to get out of
some of the more mature positions to
focus our investments on less mature
assets but longer running rooms so that
meant that UK was on the review we've
been very clear about it now at the same
time these are high-quality assets I
produce cash they do have Running Room
left and I think they are better able or
better owned by a player like Reyes or
who actually specializes in that type of
operation does it mean that we will be
out of the North Sea
from it we will be continuing to invest
in the North Sea to the tune of at least
700 million dollars a year going forward
so we will still see growth in the North
Sea now one of your peers Rex Tillerson
of Exxon Mobil has just become Secretary
of State to Donald Trump what do you
think he's going to be like in the job
but I know Rex quite well as a as a
businessman I think he was a formidable
businessman I enjoyed working with him
of course in many areas we were partners
like in the North Sea in many areas we
were competitors and I respect him an
awful lot in both roles
now he is a diplomat I'm still a
businessman so our paths have diverged
but I'm sure the skills that he brings
the qualities of character as he brings
to the role will serve them very well
president Trump is obviously quite
skeptical about climate change he's
obviously a supporter of traditional oil
and gas companies do you take
encouragement from that well it I think
first of all on climate change and the
energy transition that we are going
through and is inevitable and has also
needed in the context of the Paris
commitments I don't think that is going
to change I think that is actually
unstoppable and we need to be a company
that is right at the vanguard of doing
that and and make sure that we can not
only survive in that energy transition
but actually are a thriving company and
take advantage of the opportunities as
well I also think though that the
president will focus on clear industrial
policy I think he will probably be less
idealistic but it doesn't mean that he
will be less effective in achieving some
of the things that we are already seeing
in the United States but overall you
think he's going to create a more
favorable environment for the end
industry
well I I think he will that's of course
a stated objective I think he will
create or even aim to create a more
favorable environment for business being
the businessman that he is himself and I
think we can only be welcoming that what
that means in detail for the oil and gas
industry we will have to see I think
some of the regulatory changes that he
is proposing can be changes for the
better but at the same time we actually
also quite
regulation because it basically
heightens the bar for everybody
including ourselves